hey it's christmas from big brother all
stars and this is my e.t
post eviction interview for me
what's best for me is unfortunately
christmas
evicting you i respect how much you
fought this past week i respect how much
you fought this whole game
but this is what's best for me it's
official christmas
you have been evicted from the big
brother house
[Music]
i believe cody chose to keep nicole a
former winner over me
because they had played together
previously they
had that bond and that's really hard to
beat
i didn't have anybody from my season in
the house with me
but had i i know that i would naturally
gravitate to them
also um cody said multiple times to
multiple people that he just saw me as a
bigger competitor
so i mean he took his girl i understand
that loyalty goes a long way
[Music]
so i actually
didn't play emotionally this time i was
very strategic
in my game play i just was more
emotional this time
so my decisions weren't based on my but
my emotional reactions my decision was
based on strategy
and need for implementation of where i
needed to be in the game
i just was more upset more frequently
because i was missing my son
i was just more raw this time i was more
real i was more
me and so i did get upset a lot more
i didn't let my emotions decide
my gameplay
the only regret that i have and i hate
having regrets
i really really hate having regrets but
the only one that i have
is that i let that one pumpkin jump out
of my
my shovel that was such a game changer
for me
and you know i i have to accept it for
what it is
but man i was i was really kicking butt
in that one
[Music]
when i see davon and jerry i know that
we're going to give each other a hug
we were able to sit down before she was
evicted and really connect
more personally and separately game wise
you know i i feel that my pers
my opinion of the fact that i didn't use
bailey's personal information
in my game play was me
using just gameplay bailly and daebong
were targeting my alliance and so i made
a game move to protect my alliance
and honestly i think that she's gonna
understand it and we're gonna hug it out
and she's gonna say good game
[Music]
memphis is just a guy that i really
enjoy spending time with
i get to pick on him he helped me a lot
coping being away from my family and my
son
we're both single parents that have
little boys
so we just had a lot in common and he
was just a really great friend